all right well hello everybody welcome
to the brawl and Hall five I'm gonna try
to keep it under control up here I'm
Suzy Welch on my right is Jack Welch and
on my left Gary Vee these are two guys
who need no introduction whatsoever so I
think I'll just plunge in we are asking
you to send us your questions also you
can see the information up there a
Skrill CEOs I think is the hashtag so
let's just start right off as sort of a
brief if you would guys stay to the
Union right it's it's 2015 and the
people who are in this audience are
interested in starting businesses
getting funding hiring great people
crushing the competition yeah the ORS
yes City especially crushing the
competition if you were sitting in a bar
as you were want to do with any of the
people in this audience what would you
tell them really really excites you
about the future and what is scaring the
living daylights out of you
Gary Europe well I was gonna I was being
polite here nothing scares me and as far
as what excites me is that clearly the
Internet's promised over the last 20
years is squeezing out the middle of
anybody who doesn't bring value to me
what I feel is happening and that we're
all so lucky to be living through right
now is it feels like there's more
meritocracy right if you've got the
chops there isn't an editor there isn't
a decision-maker there isn't somebody
who's stopping you because the platform
the internet allows people to really go
direct to consumer there's no more man
there's no more machine yeah you know
especially man right like like I hate
like man right yeah and you're saying
you really believe there's no more
machine there so nothing scares you yeah
me look I'm an optimist I mean plug it
allowed me to Putin scares me like you
know where is he
you know it's Nabokov scares me you
scare me but from a business sense all
right total optimism from Gary Jack you
know what scares me it's having an idea
I mean more and more young people
country and say I want to be an
entrepreneur I say what's your damn idea
idea I want to be an entrepreneur you
don't manufacturing entrepreneurs you've
got to have something as jobs and you
gotta have something of value something
you need I want to be an entrepreneur
for career I speak to all these fancy
colleges all over the world get an idea
okay so let's say they have an idea okay
then the hard part right so what what
are the two big pieces of advice you
would give somebody who's got an idea
and wants to be an entrepreneur not
everyone can be one what are the what's
the two big piece of advice you give
somebody okay well first of all the
Jack's right but the you know for me
we're seeing so many I see so much
early-stage startup stuff and the truth
is you know ideas are commoditized a lot
of people have got the same ideas a ton
of ideas or straight [ __ ] right and so
there's that problem I think I think the
more stunning thing is I've seen a ton
of people with tremendous ideas that
have no idea how to actually execute I
think the single biggest thing that I
would tell people that I think there's a
huge disconnect between their idea and
the audience they're trying to serve the
lack of pulse of knowing who you're
trying to serve who you're trying to
sell to the value proposition right what
is the value proposition alright and the
advice you give over and over again you
get people to talk about stuff that
don't say it's like everybody wanted to
go to China in my day got me in China
they don't need you what are you
bringing that's different
why are you bringing in so you can China
is a great place if you've got something
the Chinese company needs if you're
coming over there with a bag of crap
you're nothing's gonna happen no matter
how many billion people there you have
and check that doesn't by the way like
not just [ __ ] China right like
everybody like like when you bring [ __ ]
I love when people like Gary I really
need your marketing I'm like no [ __ ]
your product [ __ ] blows
right so I think you know I know my
children aren't watching this it's Susan
is just getting started
you got fifty five minutes of this all
right so you tell them get a proper a
proper tune all right but you've got to
build a team while you're at it all
right you gotta hire somebody Gary
you're hiring a lot of people Jack you
had 400,000 people working for you at
one point what are you looking for while
you're yes four hundred thousand what
are the qualities you're looking for
there's a lot of smart people out there
know you you want smart hungry energized
people that can energize others excite
others make the case for where you're
going how you're gonna get there and get
people following you in in hungry you
want hungry people you want people with
that nose against the glass smart
passionate hungry willing to take the
hill that's what you want me or anybody
else in the game I'm obsessed with
self-awareness right somebody who knows
themselves I think is a real value to me
because Jack's right he's talking about
leaders and we've got plenty of those
and I love those people but you know
truth is especially for a younger
generation we're in this point now where
you know work-life balance or how much
money actually is needed for you as an
individual everybody in here to actually
get you to that happy place what else do
you value so to me if you show me
somebody who's self-aware even if
they're self aware that there are
b-minus in a big machine there's spots
for a lot of different players how do
you find out if somebody's self-aware
ask them are you self-aware know you for
me I watch it in their behavior right I
mean some people walk in they're like
Gary I really think that I should be an
SVP and I'm like I think you should be
[ __ ] fired
and so you know so I think that I think
that there's people their actions day in
and day out and listen I think with no
question right now especially the world
where people are are talking to the
world there's a lot more communication
right employees can talk to the world
not just inside their own buildings I I
think that the HR DNA of an organization
has never been more about
human resources to me is at the top now
not an afterthought or a checkbox I'm
telling you this is what I feared the
most about this is you guys we're gonna
agree too much because Jack you will
also think I believe it is all right
look it's a long time people have hated
on HR HR yeah but but HR is all
important in our notebook we're pitching
of real hot pitch breakup H I get the
finance the insurance the badge the crap
out of it and let that HR truly be
people development careers life style
everything and and this is a big deal
HR is always the back water back to the
last thing to hire maybe have a picnic
in the birthday with HR the rest is crap
and so you really want to just focus on
that not a bunch of stuff around Badgers
insurance don't make it all about the
people make it about the people Sue's
I'll tell you this I've had a consistent
career of firing the single most
talented people in my organization
because they were unable to play with
the other girls and boys from an HR
standpoint that to me is just a death
blow I don't give a [ __ ] if you're the
greatest of all time if nobody else
likes you get the hell out of my face
let's get personal for me now I want to
talk to you guys about valuations and
some stuff with the economy but I just
want to know you're both successful and
we all know your achievements but I want
to know about the biggest mistake you
ever made so that everybody out here
who's watching can avoid making this
mistake biggest mistake you ever made
well I'm the oldest so I made the most
fundamental fundamental e I bought
businesses based on numbers we we used
to buy a business a day 200 a year Jesus
and I made a lot of mistakes by buying
it based on numbers and not about
culture when you try and take culture a
and put it with culture be all hell
could break loose obey and me don't get
along and numbers aren't enough so when
you start doing deals and others
don't get all hung up on the numbers be
sure that fit culturally works and the
people its garrisons like each other to
work together that's a big deal
didn't you have sort of a rather
explosive mistake early in your career
Jack well I blew the roof off a building
I was a chemical engineer PhD scientist
mixing stuff and I blew the roof off the
building what I thought it was all done
I thought I was old then I met it and I
got to go to New York to meet the top
boss and because my current boss didn't
know me once I blew the roof off he
thought I was the last thing he wanted
to be near so he sent me to see his boss
I went down there
his boss happened to be a hell of a guy
he used the Socratic method what did you
do wrong how did you do it why did you
do it what would you do right the next
time
and I took my white shirt and tie and
throw better my Volkswagen and I got
back and I still had a job what did you
learn from that that absolutely don't
kick anybody when they're down you can
kick people in there when they're
swelling instead of growing think about
that you when you find people who are
swelling instead of growing you've got a
hustles ass on your hands and you're
going to have to deal with it and that's
a big deal so remember that don't pay
come on they're on their back Gary
what's the big mistake
you know I think the themes you know I
think I will repeat these mistakes
because I think they're entrenched into
my DNA I think at times I'm too patient
you know I patience is my strength but
uh
not is that not a true and not see I
think they were like laughing it's
something not our beer thanks jack I get
it I think I think I understand my
personality in the outwardness but I'm
stunningly patient if somebody digs into
the way that listen everybody forgets
you know I spent eight years building
wine library before I ever came out and
even said hello to the world I didn't
try to become you know a business coach
or a thought leader at 24 because I had
some ideas so you know III think I'm
actually too patient at times I think
the other thing that happens which is
contradicts that a little bit is at
times I get very big eyes and I try to
do four or five things at the same time
just because I think I can my ego and
bravado get the best of me and I think
that you know just by just sheer will
then I'll create victory and so those
have been the things that I need to pay
attention to all right if you're gonna
get people advice about this what would
it be I want to know for both of you
what sets off your [ __ ] meter what
sets it clanging [ __ ] go [ __ ]
and pomposity prompt us nothing's worse
than compositing like a pompous ass is
the worst thing in the world somebody
who thinks they're more important than
they are
he thinks they're somebody big it's the
worst trait known to man
hypocrisy yeah it makes my face [ __ ]
melt off yeah you know I hate when
people are hypocrites right like oh this
person's micromanaging too much and I'm
like you're [ __ ] micromanaging too
much you know to me hypocrisy kills me
all right let's go into some fast
teasers I'm gonna throw out some words
sort of hot words or hot ideas that are
going on right now and I'd love to get
your sort of fast reactions to then
we'll just go back and forth between the
two of you all right I feel like if you
would just go ahead okay great all right
all right
Facebook hot
the establishment all right
the 3d printing 3d printing early gun
control let me get a smart I wanted to
go you know but clearly most of them got
it which is like we debate these things
are like people kick don't let them buy
guns at shows and like I'm gonna [ __ ]
beat guns in like four minutes all right
interesting interesting all right
Twitter
tired attention issues the fire hose is
too loud and the attention graph is
broken on Twitter as it sits right now
Google tough to compete without that I
mean I'm in AI AC which is match.com
which has all the other search engines
and other things and Google's one tough
ass guy to do business with yep
a search company that should be
dramatically more and every second I'm
just waiting it to do that Jeff Bezos
big balls
love them okay big hairy balls okay I'm
a huge fan
I think he's as good of a CEOs all right
okay well we Jeff we obviously love you
up here all right
we heard about what about the Sony hack
who gives a [ __ ] it's this it's it's the
norm in every zone he gave it it's the
norm
everybody's gonna be hacked you're fully
on the record for the rest of your
[ __ ] lives get used to it I agree
with that totally I mean we it's true
like forget privacy right all right uber
just go public already please looking
pretty thing great great
all right here's one work-life balance
no such thing it's all about choices you
make the choices you go after them and
you live with the consequence it's good
and bad and you make your own choices
and you don't wait for some bureaucracy
to come out and tell you 100 percent
50 50 49 51 that's all crap you make the
choices you do the thing and you live
with the consequences
it's 100% right it's an individual thing
that you have to respect the people that
you've surrounded yourself with in your
life and take their feelings into
account but it's just it's such an
individual thing and when people try to
impose their work-life balance on others
without the context of their lives their
upbringing their spouses and all
variables the kids dynamics it's crazy
that's crazy
all right you know Jack and I gave a
talk one time at a conference and we
Jack said what he just said and people
in the audience stood up and walked out
I'm noticing nobody's walking now I'm
Gary you kissed him so maybe that's why
nobody's walking out it was a more
establishment all right let's just talk
about one last thing here when this in
this fast-track Texas State a great
state of Texas I think it's the greatest
place you can do big business we're
involved with three companies here and
absolutely love the whole atmosphere in
this place the energy of the pizza
people the government the taxes all
right I hate [ __ ] Texas because Texas
wholesalers liquor wholesalers paid
politicians in Texas in the back rooms
to keep wine library from not being able
to ship here while allowing everybody
else to do it so I call that communism
Jack you have a different experience
what'd you do about it
what'd you do [ __ ] about it because the
fact that matters state by state liquor
laws yeah and at the end of the day I
can't do dick about it and so [ __ ] you
Texas okay
that's sort of a lot of other states in
the wine business Texas only state that
is letting everybody else [ __ ] but me
yes Texas is the only [ __ ] state
that's doing this I think Texas doesn't
like Gary for some reason do we're gonna
Texas that's fine Terry some [ __ ]
dick face doesn't like me and was able
to get a politician to block me that's
fine [ __ ] you
how does he really feel and that's what
we need to know all right all right uh
okay uh you know look we have two
distinct
point of differentiation so on look um
you know Gary you're all new economy all
new stuff Jack is very much involved in
new economy stuff in the past ten years
but you know swam and the sort of
industrial world for a long time and so
I'm gonna ask you both this question and
see where you come out with it
what is tried and true about business
what is never going to change what is
one of the what are the immutable laws
and what is brand-new given the way the
world is change in the past five 10
years hire great people people with
passion that I talked about before
absolutely have a generosity gene this
is the thing that I have learned over
all my years it's the most important
thing a leaderless and I want you to
think of your bosses and I'm convinced
now it's a gene is your boss somebody
who hides your ideas it takes over
themselves is you bought somebody who
loves to see you get promoted is your
boss somebody who gets turned on when he
disappear she gives you a raise or a
bonus are they trying to save the
company in two cents is your career big
deal to them if they're not get your ass
away from them because the generosity
gene is what you want to look for in
your boss you want a boss that can
hardly wait to see you sprout that the
biggest turn-on in the world the biggest
turn around the world for me is I've got
41 CEOs who work for me
that's a tournament that is better than
any you can get and that's what you want
to look like don't work for the boss who
hide you with who doesn't take your idea
and shows it to their boss any of those
characteristics and so you're saying
also display this gene right I mean it's
not just yourself have this gene love to
take care of your people love to do
things for him make the atmosphere fun
work is fun and you've got to make it
that way all right so this is like one
of the immutable long-term laws of
businesses though whether you've got the
generosity either work for somebody
who's got it
or be the person
both shows it right all right immutable
law business forever and ever
supply and demand you know for me that's
the one I keep paying attention to right
now I pay most attention to the supply
and demand of attention it's why I'm
obsessed with Instagram and snapchat
because it's happening there it's why
I'm down on Twitter at this moment
because there's a firehose issue so
supply and demand really matters to me I
think about it all the time in whatever
battery I think the thing that's changed
is the level of scale right the fact
that uber or these companies in 2 3 4 5
years because the Internet has created
infrastructure and mobile devices and
all these other variables what's really
changed is you didn't have companies go
from 0 to 40 billion in valuation in 3 4
or 5 years so the scale has completely
changed and so that gives the homerun
hitting the upside the Hail Mary a very
sexy kind of halo effect which also then
leads to everybody chasing that lotto
ticket and it creates a different
dynamic
what is brand new to you jack well speed
the CB is unbelievable I mean every if
you ask me five years ago I would have
said speed and now if you ask me today
about five years ago I would have said
it was slow I mean everything is faster
I mean just take for example six months
ago how many of you thought oil would
take a dive raise your hand how many of
you do that to how many of you don't
give a [ __ ] about oil you got it
no you got a because of change and the
Euro you would you don't give a [ __ ]
about the Euro maybe no Jack get fired
up that's not the facts are they you
always changed 40% and if you're down
40% versus the dollar and if you're a
multinational you're not probably most
nine ninety nine percent of you but if
you are and you're an exporter you just
had your throat cut all your plans are
gone in six months
that never happened before so the speed
of change is negative change is
unbelievable in the markets all right
look both of you come from pretty
hardscrabble beginnings I think you know
technically Jackson have more
hardscrabble than you Gary but but deep
Odin either of you were born with silver
spoons in any orifice and so let me ask
you this when you were sort of 20 years
old what did you want to be when you
grew up the owner of the New York Jets
be a professional hockey player it's not
interesting you both wanted to be in the
sports world yep because business is a
game Joe it's big a it's big in Oh
Jack's still playing that's what sucks
up nobody understands being an athlete
blows right you looked like at 8 to 12
year window and in you're 32 over 37 and
you have to like your whole life has
been for this thing and you've got a
completely reset do you still want to be
the owner of the New York Jets okay
sorry
but you can't make one you just got read
this they could be better well why the
[ __ ] do you think I want to buy them
okay you heard it here first all right
they didn't hear you wanted you both
wanted to be in the athletic world okay
so and then what changed yeah I mean
like when did it change when did you
sort of when did you well when I went to
college and I played against Canadians
yeah you haven't given up okay all right
all right
uh Jack you're in a network Gary you
think every person can be a network
probably I do is there any future for
intermediaries in the in the media space
anymore
yeah the platforms are the intermediate
snapshots in the middle now right so the
platforms on top of the internet play
that role but clearly media's going
through a massive shift I think when you
think about over-the-top services mobile
first I mean there's such big ships and
I think people are grossly under
estimating how big of a moment snapchats
discover platform where they kind of
went to media as a core function a place
that Facebook and Twitter and Tumblr and
other places have not gone before I
think that's a an early shot to where
these things can go yeah yeah I have to
tell you this is a true generational
thing because you work I know
from previous conversations you really
think snapchats the Living End
and Jack and I whenever we get pictures
from our kids on snapchat we're like
we're really it's disappearing and we're
get very frustrated by it right
who's our entire conversation right now
is disappearing disappearing is actually
the norm that's actually how we live
documenting is new this is new with the
front row filming this is new the way
we've lived forever is disappearing
alright huh that's a very existential
thought very existential thought can I
get you guys to say each of you what
companies you think are overvalued and
what you think it's undervalued and why
Jack not man I'm just not smart enough
to know because one day Apple six months
ago eight months ago
that's just 700 bucks and they had to
split it was dead look at now so you
look at these companies valuation is in
the eyes of the buyer and there's
nothing else to say but I mean so
Microsoft was this Cisco was this now
Google's this box is this it's that the
value of whatever the market is no I
don't like the early funding when you're
getting in at these crazy valuations
before it goes public once it goes
public I think you got yourself a real
look at the market and you'll find out
if box can deliver if there's next if
shakes if she can deliver if once can
deliver they were all up public in the
last month but now we'll watch them
they've got to stop doing stuff but it's
undressing where people are all buying
big event evaluations under the radar I
can't comment all those I don't know
what it what do you think I think I
think it depends on the context of like
a timeline so I'm gonna go with let's
say a five-year timeline I think things
like I think Walmart's overpriced in a 5
to 10-year window I think they're much
more vulnerable to consumer behavior
over the next decade I think Facebook is
grossly underpriced I don't think people
really understand how good that
and product is and what we're gonna be
seeing from that over the next four to
five years and just I think zux is a
beast and underrated because he just
hasn't had time to show it for the
market so those two standout all right
just speaking of investing and starting
up companies and so forth what is the
best thing in the world that your
investors can say about you if you're
running this company what's the best
thing an investor can say about you you
mean in the private angel world or in
Wall Street let's say angel blowing
right now to me I think it's just
tenacity and willing to change their
mind my favorite my favorite founders
that I invest in are the ones who aren't
scared that in six months after they
went and told everybody that their
company was going to do X when they
taste that it's broken they're willing
to ship to why that takes a lot of
courage that takes an a player there's
way too many people in this room that
don't like to change their mind I look
at it as the reverse I only value those
who are willing to do that that means
you're adjusting to the moment of the
market at that Center and so that's what
I'm looking for I agree with that but
I'd say this you also have to do what
you say the idea of a lot of [ __ ] up
there doesn't work it'll work for a
period but if you don't deliver on what
you say credibility your credibility is
key to you all of your life that's my
way Jack I'm sort interrupts more now
than ever because now everything
everybody here is being documented to a
level we've never seen generationally
before Yeah right there's no hiding
anymore everything's being document
right so Walmart goes up ATX over the
next 10 years I'm a [ __ ] because
they keep on showing it on a constant
loop right well what's the best thing I
think Jackie we'll talk about this a
little bit if that's what your investors
you're saying you want have investors be
able to say yeah he changes when he sees
the market changing and Jack you're
saying you want them to say that guy
does or that woman does what she says
she's gonna I agree totally whoa you
can't get locked in a box you gotta be
able to move but a combination of the
two what's the best thing your employees
could say about you you talk about
generosity gene but what else what's the
best thing that people who work for you
could say about you he really cares
about me
me my life where I'm going how I'm
growing I'm just gonna you know he or
she is you know loves me no it's Bruce
you made your place because you
stunningly good-looking he's so
good-looking I can't stand it okay know
that he I think I think the thing that
I'm most proud of and there's a bunch of
employees watching and in the room is
I'm willing to adjust back to the last
answer I and they map a career plan
where we're going but I'm always
prepared for the worst
I'm always prepared for something to
happen in their lives that they can't
control that I'm willing to adjust to
and protect them the biggest thing that
I want to do for my employees is to
protect them you've got that back you've
got that back yeah it's a big one for me
people if they don't deliver and the
other thing I would say you know they
would say you got to let poor employees
know where they stand I don't know if
you guys I've done that poorly
throughout my career what I've done that
poorly I'm so obsessed with honey over
vinegar I would say over the last three
to four years
with a lot of influence by my 11 year
younger brother AJ I've gotten better at
being more straightforward because I'm
so optimistic and I'm so honey over
vinegar that I don't think I did a good
enough job in my 30s or at least my late
20s into my mid 30s of being good at
letting them know where they stood I'd
rather make a great great great great
and then fire them with a knife to their
neck all right so you know but that is
and thank God you know that because that
is the horse's ass of business when
people do that
that is the horse's ass you know people
commence a fire it's true men marry you
have to go there is just why me well
remember you really stunk a night away
having a cut back now the recession just
Dave and Marisa but I've been here 31
years let everyone who works for you
know where they stand tell them tell
them three times four times a year
that's what I like about what you're
doing and here's what you can do to
improve let's just do a little quiz here
how raise your hand in this
room if you work for somebody beside
yourself okay that's a heck of a lot of
people know how many of you bosses have
told you where you stand
a third not even I so if you're about
how many people here are bosses raise
your hand
lots of those also how many of you boss
are like a boss out of you our box how
many of you are managers of people okay
how many of you have in the past six
months told each one of your people
candidly where they stand for mature
variance okay we're gonna start taking
questions from the audience and here's
one all right it's from Scott Perry
Scott thanks so much for this great
question here is what are the top three
things that you give a [ __ ] about yes
okay I said it and the top three things
nobody should give a [ __ ] about this is
I'm so happy okay what are the top three
things you give a food about two things
nobody I like that that nobody should
give a hoot about Jack what are the top
three things that you give a hoot about
my family and nobody should give a damn
about them my school the school without
the Jack Roush management stitute where
we're building the leaders every day we
got 900 MBAs I can't paschal yeah about
that
and I care like hell about the Patriots
in the red zone jesus [ __ ] christ he
really does all right scared wait and
wonder jack just finish up okay okay
boys one of the top three things that
nobody should care about not a new
person but nobody should give a hoot
about but nobody should give it I told
the one my family nobody I mean like you
know you shouldn't care what other
people think about you I mean that kind
of thing that's what the I think the
question that I've done my piece on
there are three things I care most about
one spying on the other team's sideline
two deflating footballs
and three Canadian hockey players I
don't either
alright alright I love this one this is
from Chris hell and the question is what
have you and Joe Jack what have you and
Gary learned from each other well I can
say no I would say Gary saw us last week
some help us some stuff for our school
and what the place sat down and couches
people with laptops heads down on desks
two teams go going that stuff it's a
whole new way of doing it it was brand
new to me and it's exciting as hell I
think what you know we're getting to
know each other more and more what Jack
taught me is it's more about reaffirming
my greatest hope which is when you look
up to somebody like a jack and what he's
accomplished and when he still has that
fire right you know I pray every day of
my life in my silo of business that I'm
hustling and on fire to to the last
second right and so to me 60 70 80 90 90
I just dropped the last decade on me you
know people living longer in the dorm
but hear what he said about the Patriots
and so and so uh I think you know that
to me is the best right like like we
were in a meeting the other day we got
pissed remember about that one thing I
was like yeah I get past like he was
like I'm not [ __ ] doing that I'm like
yeah that's right I don't really pay job
jack alright Jack if you were starting a
business day Adam justice asked if you
were starting a business today what
business would you start a mechanical
engineer I'll take that background I've
been in biochemistry I said I would love
to be in biotech I would love to find
some real answers and it's a hot place
that funding is easy and there's lots of
funding out there for it and
the world of biotech is changing every
hour just like it is with the internet I
love the I love the biotech space it's
been very good to me also if you could
go back 25 years what business would you
start that's a good question
maybe maybe something like a Nike you
know to me I think that my legacy plays
out professionally by building a
consumer facing brand at scale so some
of the iconic consumer brands that have
started an Under Armour or something of
that nature
speaks to make Grey Goose something like
that mmm no all right no I didn't have
the guts that you had Gary or someone in
this room at I went to a big fat company
called GE and I was the first employee
in a plastics business in the lab and so
I started I hired my first technician so
it was a good communicator there were
just two of us and so I started a
business in the shell over the
electrical company a plastics business
now we grew it to 15 billion dollars
over a period of time but it was always
under the shell I wasn't now getting
funding I was able to steal employees
from other places I had a good brand
steal employees so well I was an
entrepreneur a cowardly entrepreneur
you'd call me because I wasn't out in
the street hustling I had this the
mother ship protected me and they didn't
know anything about plastics from Jay
levy
what is the toughest business decision
you ever had to make
Gary what's the toughest business
decision probably walking away from
day-to-day operations of Wine Library
right I mean I built that with my dad
it's my baby
it's it's my dad is my dad right and and
my hero came to this country with no
money in 100 bucks and I made a American
Dream conceal just you know a foundation
for us so making that leap and it made
it much easier than I was going to start
a business with my brother who you know
is an absolute love of my life so you
know I think that I think that was still
tough though as much as this amazing new
chapter with my bro who's 11 years
younger than me and
if anybody has sibling separations at
that scale you understand that there's
some fatherly you know there's a
different dynamic it was still tough to
like think that you know those hundred
fifty people at Wine Library bought into
me yeah for the most part that was that
was tough yeah all right jack
well I was just close to becoming
chairman I was vice chairman and I was
running for office and I wanted to and I
have a speech impediment as you all know
now and my Stan was always in my way and
I when I was a young engineer I saw this
guy who was a slick speaking beautiful
speaking guy yeah must be awesome for
president of another big chemical
company then I became vice chairman I
could bring him back so everybody in HR
cuz I I know I'm twenty years before
everybody nature I was and so I became a
real pain in the ass and threw over in
there and convinced the chairman at the
time I gotta have this guy I hire him
and he turns out to be a drunk try that
one
you right at the edge of day I'm getting
the top job you pushed aside the system
you blew the place up to get him and
he's a bum what you do I finally
swallowed went down and said we gotta
take him out
I think it's why I got the job I think
it's one of the big reasons I got the
job it's good you want what I ate my
mistake he changed I led mud all over my
face
my arrogance dropped my arrogance
quotient dropped about 50% and I became
a better person part but it was a brutal
thing because what most people do when
they high up weak people they try and
hide them and do the work farm because
they don't want to ever admit that they
screwed up it's a common characteristic
and they said don't do it yeah that's a
long story I think you know like you
make a lot the funny thing about the the
hard business decisions is they stay
with you I think Gary while you were
talking I could still feel how painful
that and how hard that decision was to
you did you never regretted it did you
know and and even more interestingly
when I look back at my career you know I
often times think what would have
happened if I went right to tech early
on or something else and not went in the
family business
yeah the slow curve that that created
but I don't regret that because all the
time I start with my dad I mean you know
look I mean decisions are decisions you
got to make it yep I let's talk about
MBAs for a second and we had a question
from Osvald I'm not wearing my glasses
of Aldo Yahya no okay although I says
Jack do you still still see any value in
business schools yeah look if you get if
you've got two years and the time to
take off and go do it and you get
another notch in your belt you learn a
lot absolutely but I got a better
solution we got a book for $25 it's
called the real life yeah go get it
right hook them jack right hook them
really might hook them Jack right now
that was just loaded by CNBC I mean by
CEO magazine it's the number one
Business School in the u.s. on line
number one cost thirty nine thousand
dollars you learn today you practice
tomorrow and you share on Friday and you
get yourself fantastic right to your MBA
okay all right let's find out what Gary
wants to sell gary anything you want to
sell i want to sell spying on the
sidelines deflating footballs are you
saying you don't love Tom Brady I do not
love Tom oh my god
can we just take a vote on Brady
there's like five hurry oh this is Texas
but no week is asking Millennials are
launching starts has been it come a
trend are they really ready or do they
under value corporate experience
millennial week I think that they could
be ready
I was ready at 22 there's you we've seen
a ton of people being ready I think that
we have an audacity now because of
startup culture that everybody thinks
they're always ready always and so and
and that actually goes even to a more
interesting place I actually am
prejudiced against people who are Ivy
League schools who've been protected in
private schools who I often judge
wrongly by the way that they don't have
the stomach for the market right I've
seen a lot more success with the scrappy
in the streets play than the people that
have been kind of coddled a little bit
along the way because the market doesn't
give a [ __ ] where you went to school
no and companies don't the day after you
get there that's a really good point the
day after you get I'm 14 years old says
Rodney Yale Ford what interests did you
have but you were when you were 14 that
led to your position today playing
sports pitching playing hockey and a
ferocious golf competitor when I was 12
and I Teddy when I was 9 do you remember
anything from high school or college
whatsoever Jesus Christ Susie I already
know the answer I wouldn't ask the
question I mean he just was not about
school he was about sports where you
know I graduate school I know you
learned oh you weren't saying he was old
as [ __ ] you know well that's right I
think that's what they know no okay
thank you Gary that is not at all the
meaning of that question yes to face it
with this guy so no I did that way
I mean call it school it was not about
school like when you were a math teacher
was the golf coach I didn't have to go
to class play golf there's all sports
all the time Gary what when you were 14
I was an F student making $2,000 a
weekend selling baseball cards it became
the entire foundation of my success so
every pair of shoes out there telling
their kids to study and so forth tell
them just to play sports and sell cards
all right Jennifer and Jennifer no sorry
I the way for a second for a second
obviously not and haha but way too many
parents are not being self-aware
are not auditing their children properly
and are not putting them in the best
position to succeed and in emphasizing
their entrepreneurial or athletic or
other artistic skills they're trying to
force them into getting good grades
because it's the parents who care about
their self-esteem around their other
[ __ ] parent friends look the problem
is that I mean the pie thing between us
we have eight children and I will just
say that you start off saying I'm gonna
help my kid figure out who they are and
I'm gonna help them become who they are
and what they're really good at and then
you get sucked into the vortex of
getting your kid into college and it
makes you insane five and two and guess
what on the record in 15 years to me
right now I don't give a [ __ ] what they
do I just want them to do what they're
best at and I I don't give a [ __ ] about
what the other parents think of me I
don't need to live vicariously it's my
kids because I'm gonna get mine by
myself right you can say good look self
actualize yourself so you don't have to
self-actualize through your kids the
question from Jennifer dasari is what is
that that's gratuitous advice from the
moderator what is the moderators on fire
I think the moderator stop talking
what's the best piece of advice you've
ever received both Jack and Gary what's
the best piece of advice you've ever see
great qua personal Chuck because it's
quick that my my dad grabbed me at 15
when I started working 14 when I started
working the liquor store and as you can
tell by my personality I had plenty of
natural [ __ ] salesmanship kind of
bravado DNA and he looked me dead in the
face and he
that he goes heavy Russian accent if you
ever buy something you keep it what he
meant by that was you stick to your word
right word was bond and that horse my
dad pushed against my natural DNA gave
me the balance that is an enormous
enormous backbone to my success
fantastic Jack best that's well my Bible
said I was I I worked in up in a remote
location for GE I ran my own show I came
to work now and what looks like casual
clothes it was a big deal bandit isn't
and then I got down to the headquarters
just before the final job gets in and
I'm and I'm appointed to the board four
of us as nice gym it I go to my first
board meeting I'm in a white shirt
striped tie a blue suit
I'm as packaged as I can be and I go the
blue bag and I don't say that and Paul
Austin who was the CEO of coke comes up
to me after make sense Jack the reason
we gave you this job and the reason
we're looking at you is you might shake
this old place up be yourself
guess what the girl who brought you here
be yourself don't end up you don't look
right in this program and it's not gonna
work
stay stay eccentric like who you are
change as you learn about yourself
be flexible but understand be yourself
at the core don't try to change for
where you're working
um can you Sally and Koontz asks please
can you please rank an order of
importance luck intelligence and hard
work backwards hard work
intelligent luck
I'd put intelligence and I put luck and
hard work in the same pot okay all right
nobody's asking me so I'm not gonna
answer wait this says Jared Loftis says
what first build the team to get the
company and it's Reb potential or build
revenue so you can afford to the team
this is the this is the entrepreneurs
dilemma I mean what do you do what did
you build if you don't have the money
you're not in the game right so you've
got to have you know one or the other
when AJ and I started vaynermedia
we didn't take any funding but I went
out and hustled a couple pre-sales
campaign works and asked them for the
money up front and we used that money to
start the engine right so if you don't
have that luxury you know the chicken
and egg is is not as much a chicken and
egg as people think you need cash to
stay alive so that's how but yeah and
how you get it what the time it is right
you'll figure out but don't ever forget
one thing business is that game we
talked about and the best team wins so
without question forget to play game his
crap the best team wins often times
well we're small group you need nothing
more than a big fat company does
everybody was a small group and
brightest you can and then get lucky
all right there's a homicide of some
with one [ __ ] then you had four
hundred thousand people right right
that's where it got to started with him
all right let's let's this is a great
question it's about mentors from Isabel
do more ta I think who was your mentor
and what is the most memorable moment
you had with that person well I'm
against business I think that mentoring
is [ __ ] particular company because
you get assigned to a mentor anybody
home brain into the bedroom it is
unpopular the mint is a dick and you
know all of a sudden a dick because
that's your mentor
you want to have everybody as a mentor
The Wall Street Journal cement amendment
Zuckerberg Samantha Beezus is a mentor
you want to read and learn from Gary
Samantha you want to grab and touch
every person and don't get trapped in
that corporate crap on mentoring where
you get a person and you get stuck and
you're saying you have mentors of people
that you know there's messes giv give
you the parking lot and the directions
to the men's and ladies room that's
right Yusei jack have these mentors
you're talking about people who don't
you don't even know you just said you've
all people who knows you want to learn
about them and understand at all
everybody Samantha carries a mentor but
you need to mentor than me but you
hadn't been as but you also had mentors
like sigh I mean you had real mentors
who say yeah yeah yeah you get some but
I mean you don't want to think of it you
want to have everybody and mentor
everything as a mentor like getting the
Wall Street Journal talking about it
that's arguable the face book as a vet
is valued right on Twitter's right or
something else's newspaper and it's
information it's a mentor so everything
is a mentor Gary you know it's
interesting I was listening it's similar
to my answer was gonna be the market is
the mentor and I think that's what
you're deserving yeah you know I think I
you know I mean at the end of the day my
parents mentored me to be a person but I
was too egotistical as a kid to allow
anybody to come in like I actually under
educated myself on purpose
because I wanted to be internal to my
intuition all right you know no I know
I'm just thinking about whether or not
there's a follow-up question about
whether yeah your father was obviously
your first mentor my dad and I didn't we
agree on [ __ ] all right
right he taught me the the word is bond
but Mike I grew my business from three
to twenty five million dollars in three
years and my dad called an all-hands on
meeting because somebody was [ __ ]
stealing peanuts we didn't see the world
the same way I here's a question to
business
magic Paulo asks and I'm gonna broaden
this question the question is what's the
last book you read another question I
know we make this may be a very short
answer for both of the two of you but
well let's just talk about what you read
in general when you wake up in the
morning you got to fill your head with
stuff to get going to give you
perspective what do you read what was
the last if you read a book recently
what was it what was and what do you
read in general on a regular basis what
should people in the audience be reading
I mean when I write my next book that
will then match the amount of books that
I've written to read so that's not a
good all right so you're not reading
books ok but here's what I am talking
about but here's what it is it's back to
the last question I'm reading the 4,000
emails a day I'm getting thousands of
tweets I'm reading the market yeah but
do you read anything any websites is
there anything you go to every morning
do you read All Things D just
insider.com that's insider.com well
that's right there with you Jack me what
are you reading I have about the same
rereading appetite as you do but I'd get
the real-life MBA no matter what you do
and all goes to charity I want you to be
shameless but more importantly Business
Insider the journal the New York Post
but I don't want I don't want to be in
it I've done that I get it
alright this is weird two more questions
and we're gonna wrap it up we're getting
to the end Jack and Gary Lawrence
Edmonson asks were you ever scared that
you would fail and if so how'd you get
past it always constant paranoia i I see
competition everywhere I looked I always
tried to take a product that we're never
will need again and make it better
I heard the quote the other day from
from Tim Cook at Apple it was a fabulous
quote when I lived by I never had the
quote a chance he said I never worry
about the competition I worry about
beating my last release I won my next
product to beat the hell out of my last
wheelie
that's a great thought you don't want to
get all hung up against the competition
you want to just get better and better
and better to me there's a very big
distinction between respect and scared
I've never been scared but I respect the
competition I respect that it's out
there but but but I've never been scared
I'm not paranoid the way Jack is
describing no I think I think for me
once I realized who I was at a very
young age I was scared about science
class in sixth grade because I knew my
mom would be upset that I got an F yeah
but but I was when it came to business
I've never had a day like that in my
life
I'm scared about the health and
well-being of my family
yeah but business that context never we
had 70 thousand people in our company
with stock options and that is one brick
up on your back because you're out there
every day if that stock freitas you can
think of all those lives that are wet
and so you up that is a breath to carry
and the joy of them getting on a Friday
night that the stock went from up five
thousand percent over this period and
the joy of going in and seeing the
sheets Friday night of who exercised how
many options was the turn on of all time
and to see that all taken away from them
was a crazed paranoia that I have it
drove me nuts it's great it was the
worst obligation it just felt it every
minute let's just all right so I was
scared all right let's just have some
parting words or at the end here I'm
just gonna give you both free rein just
just say you know what send people out
with the message about you know if you
want them to have one thought as they go
out and think about getting business
right
winning crushing the competition
inventing inventing themselves and
inventing companies what would be this
last parting words of advice that you
would give this crowd self-awareness and
empathy it's how you're gonna win stop
bullshitting yourself start giving a
[ __ ] about other people that is going to
put you in a very strong position
care a lot about what you do everything
you do relationships your business have
a passion for it and can care about just
about everything and be authentic while
you're caring all right thanks guys